alafé wakili journaliste directeur
général du quotidien ivoirien
l'intelligent d'abidjan
alafé wakili merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors avant de
revenir sur la situation dans le pays
peut être un mot sur la demande du
président ivoirien il a prôné un ce
jeudi auprès des nations unies
le recours aux droits de tirage spéciaux
c'est une sorte de monnaie créée par le
fmi pour aider les pays africains à
faire face à l'impact économique de
l'épidémie
kovy de 19 la situation économique est
plus que préoccupante aujourd'hui sur le
continent où elle est préoccupante mais
on ne pourrait pas dit qu'elle est plus
que préoccupante et là l'image de la
situation dans plusieurs pays au monde
et l'annulation de la dette a été
préconisé des visas tir continu comme
celle de droits de tirage spéciaux
maintenant la question aussi c'est la
prêtrise si on a trop de dette qui on en
fait trop si lorsque la crise est là il
faudra toujours bien payé et puis subit
donc côté une des solutions alors au nom
la situation en côte d'ivoire détention
avant les élections qui se profilent
le conseil constitutionnel a validé la
candidature d'alassane ouattara mais pas
celle de guillaume soro ou de laurent
gbagbo pour quelles raisons dioum soro
et laurent gbagbo ils ont été condamnés
par la justice ivoirienne c'est son tir
manqué qui leur est reproché et cette
condamnation a fait qu' ils ne sont pas
sur la liste électorale or pourront être
éligibles pour pouvoir être candidat il
faut être lecteurs ils ont figuré sur la
liste électorale
c'est la principale raison qui est leur
a été opposé
ils ont entre et d'eric ou qui n'ont pas
prospéré
donc quand ils ne sont pas sur la liste
électorale ne sont pas électeur et le
conseil constitutionnel a indiqué qu'il
n'était pas possible qu'ils le soient
éligibles
est-ce que c'est reçu ça donne dans le
pays par le peuple ivoirien
quelles sont les réactions bon les
nations bien entendu sont actuellement
négative
les différents états majors dans les
différents partis politiques
il faut dire ici que comme tout et
partout dans le monde il reste difficile
de déterminer
c'est peut être le petit voyait en tant
qu une seule entité une seule voie
actuellement mais toujours est il qu'il
ya une opposition qui est l'une a dit
malgré ses contradictions elle parvient
se rassembler pour dénoncer en
particulier peut-être les traits des
candidatures est aussi l'accueil natif
du privé alassane ouattara mais ça
participe aux divisions ici qu'il a dans
le pays
il n'est pas possible de donner une idée
d'une opinion générale ou majoritaires
en des eaux des élections qui arrivent
tellement vous parlez d'une opposition
soudée une opposition qui considère la
candidature d'alassane ouattara comme
illégal car il a déjà effectué deux
mandats c'est le maximum mais pour le
conseil constitutionnel les compteurs un
retombe à zéro
au vu de la constitution 2016 c'est
réellement le cas à une opinion
personnelle aussi la question en
fonction de simple occupation pour sur
ses convictions mais du point de vue du
droit n'a été prouvée mais ce que je
veux éviter c'est que même ceux qui
contestent la candidature du présent
mais connaissent à des niveaux que c'est
un acte est possible en admettant que
s'il y avait une élection anticipée
c'est à dire il a fait un premier mandat
2010 2015
le second mandat et en 2015 et puis la
nouvelle concession 2016 en
reconnaissant que s'il y avait une
élection anticipée en 2016 2017 2018 en
tout cas avant le 31 octobre 2020 le
conte aurait seignal 0 n'est ce pas une
manière de dire que oui le contact est
qu'on se dit qu'on me albert aussi la
possibilité d'une élection anticipée
pourrait remettre le compteur à zéro et
ne pas permettre d'être visible sur le
fait de dire à 10 en fait deux
direction 2d lisibilité deux
candidatures peu importe qu'il ait une
élection anticipée ou pas le compteur ne
peut pas être zéro mais ils s'ils ne
leur est pas possible d'entrer dans
cette rigidité absolue si une élection
anticipée aurait pu endurer argumenté je
pense que il est possible sauf
disposition expresse dans la nouvelle
concession relativement aux prix dans
l'exercice de permettre cette
candidature point de vue de légal
d'autant plus que c'est la même chose en
guinée c'est la même chose dans d'autres
pays qui ont eu ce type de situation
alors les partis d'opposition on le
disait unis contre la candidature de
ouattara sur place qu est ce que vous
sentez est ce qu'on peut craindre que la
russe mobilisent et est-ce qu'on peut
assister à des nouvelles violences sans
vous oui c'est possible pour baisse plus
personne ne peut déterminer ce qu'il
peut se passer mais ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que il ya la tension wii qui monte
mais aussi à une détermination partagée
à tous les niveaux l'opposition est vent
debout mais on sent de part et d'autre
de la fiabilité de loi collin de
l'énervement ça peut dégénérer comme
aussi la responsabilité peut prévaloir
et le sens de la responsabilité peignant
navarre en plomb d'ailleurs penser que
qu'elle est pour l'instant le cas
puisque malgré l'appel à la
désobéissance civile lancé l'opposition
peut-être donald encore d'essence au
dialogue avec les consultations
entreprises par les nations unies où le
moment qu'ils rencontrent les différents
acteurs attendant certainement qu'un
rapport soit fait dans ces comptes et
cela les appels pour les actions
effectives de désobéissance civile peut
être consistant éventuellement à parader
le pays à manifester à tout bloquer avec
aussi de la riposte éventuellement du
gouvernement tout cela ne pas encore en
jeu on peut donc penser que le dialogue
souterraine qui se passe à travers
d'autres organisations amené à baisser
la tension comme aussi ça peut jouer et
puis la conscience en coin encore
jusqu'au 31 octobre mais on espère que
ce sera l'aspect positif qui va
prévaloir de part et d'autre merci à la
féuo attili pour votre éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
directeur général du quotidien ivoirien
est l'intelligent d'abidjan